well this is the 26th annual
Christmas lecture and and and for for 20
years we call it the Christmas tree
lecture uh the idea was that uh he uh
well trees is what one of the most
important things to computer scientists
and every year I I learned at least two
new cool things about trees and so I I
so I could just talk every every
December I could talk about the coolest
thing I learned about trees that year
and that went on for more than 20 years
now I I still learn cool things about
trees every year but they're getting
harder and harder to explain to a
general audience so so so so starting
about about you know five or six years
ago we just changed it to the Christmas
lecture but but this year it's it's
again a Christmas tree lecture because
because I got you know last year uh when
I was putting the final touches on on
this this book uh volume 4B of the art
of computer programming can hey see that
um uh I I I learned something that I
said oh yeah this is going to be a great
lecture and so I'm going to have fun fun
tonight uh I mean from a lecturer's
point of view the uh it's always best
when you have something that you love to
talk about so um uh now speaking of uh
Christmas uh by the way this book makes
an excellent present and uh so so you
know if if somebody
doesn't know what to give you uh as a
gift uh why not try try suggesting this
one uh and and another thing uh I have a
tradition uh
of of uh of giving away books at this
lecture every year so if you look in
front on the floor there's a they're
quite a few but actually there's there's
three times as many books this year
because uh we've had two more years to
accumulate what happens is that uh my
books keep coming out you know in in new
editions and every printing is a little
bit different and I have to check to see
whether they followed it up again
um and and also I get books are
translated and and uh uh I only need one
copy of a translation and so what they
send me to and so on so I have extra
spare copy of the book uh and they're
sitting here but they I have two rules
about these books uh the first rule is
only one per person
and the second rule is uh you have to
wait until the end of the in the lecture
in order in order to touch them uh I
want you know somebody to to stay for
the whole thing now um
I'm gonna I'm gonna sit down now and uh
and most of it is going to be uh uh
about these these three topics uh that
are announced Twin Trees uh bacter
permutation and floor plan and so we
start with number one is Twin Trees
uh
you can't see the top
whoops
I can't either
um
all right
now uh
this is this an idea goes to um
I I got the two guys named look and
green bear
in uh
and uh
and I have to say that it's one word uh
uh in 1996 they actually cut they called
it Twin Trees uh with a space between it
and uh but then it turned out that that
that two other guys came up with a
completely different Concept in 1993
that was called uh Twin Trees and so in
they wrote These Guys wrote another
paper in 1996 in 1998 and and uh called
it twin binary trees well I think you
know that that I like to make it just
one word so I'm so I'm calling it twin
tree uh and and the topic is in volume
Four B uh in in in in in two main
exercises there's what one on page 27
about Baxter fermentation then there's
this one on page 172 and if you if if I
zoom in here on this you'll see that it
actually
uh talks about where do we can you see
wait a minute here we go I got floor
floor plans but I also have twin tree
okay but here you see I
I still spell it with two words there uh
and the third printing is going to
change that uh
but what are they so so like
well you might uh
you might guess that that they're
they're trees it's a pair of binary
trees
a binary
tree is a tree in which every node has
either no children or well heck it has
potentially two children a left child
and a right child
um
and and both of them uh uh
have uh nodes one through n
um when you look at the tree in
symmetric order
and I'll tell you what symmetric order
is it it it it
in a minute then and the easiest thing
is for me to just give you an example of
a a of a twin tree
um
because because a twin tree is a pair of
binary trees
um and so uh well it's Christmas time so
I'm going to draw the first one uh in
green
and uh it so so I have a node here
number four and then then here's two and
here's one three
uh six
five this is going to be this is going
to be a binary tree with eight nodes in
it
um
and uh
symmetric order
uh
so this is in symmetric order
symmetric order you you you take the
left subtree first and do it in
symmetric order then you take the root
then you do the right subtree and
symmetrical so it's just reading it from
left to right it goes one two three four
five six seven eight
and and uh but and and then uh
uh well there's two of them so he to the
other one
is this five uh eight
seven
six
I gotta do something over here let's go
all the way to one
uh three two four
so this is an example of a twin tree
data structure
and uh
the the
uh the the important concept is that
node K has a
it has a right child let's say
in exactly one of the two trees
um
and and the same thing for a left child
in exactly one of the trees so uh this
is this is when K is uh between one and
N but not equal n and this is when K is
between 1 and N but not equal to one
because one always
one never has a left child uh one is the
first thing in symmetric order so you
can't have a left show well now uh so so
let's let's let me just show the left
left and right children here so
um
let's see I
assume that a little bit so if if I if I
look at one two three four five six
seven eight and and I write down there
uh the the left
and right children
um
uh this is going to be left and this is
going to be right and and uh the root of
the tree is four
but then the children of four are two
and six left
okay children of two are one and three
uh children of six or five and seven
and it turned the seven uh eight has a
seven has a right child
now if I go to uh
the red tree it its root is five it's
got the left
um one and right is eight uh eight it
has left is seven seven has left to six
you know one has right of three three
two four okay so here here you see that
uh this is you know inside a computer I
I can share the red and the green stuff
uh as long as I have a way to tell which
is red and which is green they don't
interfere with each other exactly you
know k equals four that yeah
four is going to have a right child in
one of the trees and and uh but not but
but not in two so not going to be any
clashes all right so uh now you might
think that this is this is a really uh
unusual uh uh construction I mean you
know here we have
um
maybe you have to to search until you
find such a magical thing that has this
that has this great property but in fact
there are more than ten thousand uh Twin
Trees of order eight and in order to
verify that I'm gonna I'll just let's
just generate a random one uh right now
so
um
uh I I I'm going to need the help of the
people in in the in the front row uh so
I'm gonna I have a random permutation
um
and uh
and actually uh uh uh okay so so I'm
going to ask you
there's going to be a two in here it's
going to be either on the right or the
left of one uh which should I what
should I do
to the right I just wonder if you were
conservative or liberally
foreign
just say middle left or right middle
okay I shouldn't have said anything
about conservative and stuff like that
okay nope
number four there's four places to put
it uh what do you think
okay now uh this is looking random
enough like I'm going to ask for the
next one uh because
one and three okay
now we got three more to go so uh
all right and
um are you ready to the left of one
until we have extreme
extremists here
now I'm gonna I'm gonna ask uh
now I'm gonna I'm gonna show you uh one
of my favorite algorithms of all time
Sydney held for more than 50 years is
the is the algorithm called binary tree
insertion and and it you take a
permutation and you uh
uh uh and and you write down the first
element and can you put that in the root
then you then you look at the next one
and if it's less than uh that then the
root will you go to the left so one goes
here uh uh
the next one is five well five is also
less than seven but but it's bigger than
one you know so three is less than seven
it's going to go in this uh left subtree
somewhere it's bigger than one less than
five so three comes in here uh two equal
two wow one it's it's uh
going like this
eight here we go
and four so eight seven is less than
seven oh it's less than five so here
here's four and six like it's gonna it's
gonna stick in here all right so uh it
in my uh in my uh uh well let me do the
red ones though because so anyway you
you can get any binary tree from some
permutation but now let's take the same
permutation do it right to left so we so
we put the six here and then uh then we
insert the four so the four has to go
left of the six and then the eight uh
has to go to the right and the two has
to go left to three is less than six is
less than four uh five is is less than
six bigger than four uh one called
sticks all the way here and seven is
going to be here okay so now we got this
uh this thing and I'm I'm hoping I did
it right because it's supposed to give
us a twin tree
so it's one two three
four five six seven eight forget this
and seven is the root here seven has one
and
eight
um
one has five to the right five has three
and six three has two and four
um
and uh six uh is the root of this guy
and it's got four and eight
looking good so far
four has two and three and two has one
um
two has three sorry four has two and
five
yeah
so and of course these are all okay so
so now uh it worked so so we get lots
and lots of any permutation is going to
give you a a twin tree but there's going
to be you know a lot of times
two different permutations are going to
give you the same the same twin tree and
we'll have to we'll have to worry about
that but but why does it always work
well that are the rule the reason is
that lfk
is uh is empty if and only if
uh K minus 1 was inserted into this into
this uh this thing back before k
you see why this is I mean let's take
let's take uh four for example so so if
if if uh if if three came before four
then I'm I couldn't possibly have a left
child B on four because because you know
four would have to be somehow uh they're
nothing between three and four
you would have to go so so uh and this
is the same but with K plus one
inserted before it came so so uh
in in
uh so so if if we reverse the
permutation K minus one is going to go
the other on the other side and so it it
can't they can't both be ill all right
they can't both be R and and there's no
room they have to fill up also because
because there's just enough there's
enough total room uh and and by the way
this is also if I plug in K plus 1 for K
here this is also uh the same as saying
RK minus one
is unequal to uh now and this one is
saying L of
K plus 1 is unequal now so so if you
look at any of these diagrams and you
look at at the things that are
diagonally opposite there's always going
to be you know this is green red red
green
red red green green red red green well
this was two this was too uh uniform but
but that you know that always happens
that you have one of them is green and
one of them is ready if I if I look at
at that okay so now this is something
you know uh this transition algorithm
has been something that I that I was
playing with through the mid from the
middle 60s and I always and I've used it
in a zillion computer program but I
never took 50 years before I uh before I
understood that it also gave me Twin
Trees at the same time
all right now my plan is to I'm talking
about three things two entries back to
permutations and floor plan and so I'm
going to tell you you know about each of
each of the three uh at first and and
they they're going to set and in fact
the arrow is completely different by
completely different groups of people
they didn't know
what they were yeah they didn't know
about each other at first and uh and
then I'm going to explain why there's
amazing connection between all all these
these things so next then is um a
bachelor permutation
and and this is Glenn Baxter
um 1964.
and he was studying uh continuous
functions uh fixed points of continuous
functions but it during the course of
the study he he came up with some
permutations that that had peculiar
properties and the more he looked at
them and other people started looking at
him uh uh the more properties they were
discovering I I think I first heard
about Baxter permutations when John
Colorado gave a lecture to the math
department in the early 70s
so what are they uh well um
uh we we have a permutation of the of
the numbers uh one to n
uh
um you know of of the numbers one to n
and uh and then I can I take the inverse
permutation
um
it
it uh so so Q uh the idea is uh uh that
the inverse permutation
tells you like qk
um
equals L if and only if PL equals K it
tells uh it tells me where does K appear
in the permutation uh and uh and so so
you know inside a computer if we if we
want to com uh if somebody tells us what
p is uh we we quickly uh we quickly
compute it by saying Q of P of L
equals l
you know for all L
you're given p and then you immediately
can calculate Q inside uh so so anyway
let's do it for this random permutation
that we came up with a minute ago so
that was five
seven one five three
two eight four six
uh and uh that's p uh and so Q is uh
well one appear input position two
um so one okay let's let's do the seven
so seven I get a one one gets a two five
gets a three uh three gets a four
two gets a five eight gets a six four
gets a seven and eight gets uh no what
did I do wrong six gets an eight
that's true six get six gets an eight
eight and six I switched okay that's
that's fine so um
foreign
Baxter permutation has no bad cases
no bad configurations with uh uh where
where the first kind of a bad
configuration
is uh it is uh formally I says q k is
less than L PL is less it is greater
than K PL plus one this is this looks
very scary but I'm going to explain it
why it's actually
not scary at all but but you look it up
in Wikipedia and it'll tell you this
definition and then there's a second
case
which is bad and that is is q k plus one
less than l
uh P L S and K B L plus one
is greater than K so and q k is greater
than L now um
now so
you got a question yeah
generate Q again how did I generate Q
yeah I I I uh L equals one up to n so so
I looked at P1 and it's equal to seven
so I said Q7 equal to one
all right yeah thanks for asking yes but
please interrupt if I could
so
um you know I said Pete I I said q1
equal to 2 Q 5 equal to three
q-64. now um but but qk less than L
says that uh uh uh uh and and Q K plus 1
is greater than L6 you know so so here's
let's say PL and pl plus one are sitting
here uh then q k is
k k is some K is somewhere off on the
left K plus one is somewhere off on the
right uh if I'm looking at positions L
and L plus one of this of this
permutation uh and uh but here uh K plus
q k plus one is less than L that means K
plus one is appearing here and K is
appearing on this side but now PL is
some number that's bigger than k and pl
plus one is some number less than k and
so so
and this would be this is a less than
Canada so so if if we consider a
particular number K to take you know
this has to this has to work for
for any any k l uh uh I I don't want any
I don't want to have any any Badness
here uh it it says that uh we can take
we can take for a fixed number okay
let's say k equals four uh the numbers
that are that are bigger than four let's
call Big and and the numbers that are
less than four let's call small it says
I can't have a big followed by a small
as L varies that means that means I have
a big one followed by a small between K
and K plus 1. if if if K appears before
K so if four appears before 5 I can't
have a yeah I I I can't have a big guy
and then a small guy and then and and uh
so so the um uh uh the other the other
case is similar if if I have K plus one
uh occurring uh before k then I look at
all the numbers between the two and I
can't have a small Follow by a big
so so the uh the now sort of the
smallest possible uh
non-baxter permutation is uh is actually
one of the most famous uh
permutations that are of all is three
one four two
um
you see take take k equal to two uh and
so so one is is small and four is Big so
I have you know I I have a a small
followed by a big here
are you with me now why is this such a
famous permutation well I call it the pi
mutation because uh you get you know
everybody knows that Pi is 3.142 and and
but but but
for years uh I've been uh working with
permutations and and I I've done
countless problems where I have a
conjecture about the way permutations
work and if the conjecture is false it
almost always fails at the pi mutation
so
there's something about this that makes
it uh that makes it uh uh uh important
so the other thing is uh the inverse of
the of the Prime mutation which is which
is also the left to right uh reversal of
it uh that feels that filled the first
case here here two occurs before three
so and we have a big number uh uh
followed by a little number okay so so
this
if n equals 4 these are the only two
non-baxter permutations and there's 24
you know four factorial is 24 so so so
there's 24 so n equals four
um uh then we have 22 Baxter
permutations and for three two and one
it uh they all they're all fine and and
we get to 5 through 92 out of 120 and 6
was 422 of 7 was uh 20 74 and 8 is 10
000 754. now
um
eight factorial is uh about forty
thousand so we got a chance of something
like uh one in four that this random
permutation that you guys came up with
is is Baxter how are we going to check
to see whether
7153-2846 is Baxter
is it bad or not well we just have to
check K and K plus 1 and see what's big
and small between so so one and two is
never a problem because everything is
there's not there's no small numbers
between one and
nothing less than one so but so so what
one and two number five but two and
three there's nothing between them
between three and four though uh we've
got uh you know two is uh
um is small and eight is big and that
that's that's that's bad yeah you know
it it it's like three one four two no
it's not no no this is fine
this was fine this is three followed by
four so no problem four or five uh now
we've got a not now we've got to have uh
uh two and three are small and eight is
Big so that's no good uh so so here's a
counter example where K is four K plus
one and we have a smaller a small
followed by large that's the uh
so uh well it's not a back to
presentation but uh
we could go on five to six uh uh it it
seems uh the small guys are two and two
three four and the biggest eight so
there's a mixture of small and nice so
so it's failing on that one too so this
is yeah okay uh but anyway uh
uh a lot of permutation to our back
strategy as as you can see from these
counts and uh and uh it's not too hard
to check a given one by just you know
just by going hopping from one to two to
three to four if I eat for each each
time you hop you look at the things
between that you and you see if the bad
bad and and little guys in uh uh uh are
in the right order or not
um now um
uh one thing we can see uh in order in
order to get an idea is if if if I have
a baxter permutation I can take it I can
flip it left to right and I get another
bacter permutation uh well the reason is
sort of that rule this the first rule
slips into the second row
another another thing is I I can take a
if I have a back to permutation and I uh
take this inverse uh again I get a
baxter permutation because we just we
sort of Switched the q's and P's around
so so uh uh uh and uh but but the uh you
can also put one next to each other so
suppose I have a a baxter permutation of
one one to M here this is some Baxter
permutation and here I have another
Bachelor permutation of M plus one
through uh uh uh through n so so these
are our numbers one to m in some order
but they but they qualify as Baxter and
here it's the same thing except I added
M to M to each of them so I got a you
know I took another box of permutation
but promoted every number make it make
it bigger bigger than them uh this is
going to be this is going to be fine why
because I go from one to two to three to
four or and so on and I don't get any
bad cases here uh and and then I jump
from M to M plus one look well all of
this all of the small guys are going to
be are all going to come
first and the big guys later
between M and M plus one and then then
once I'm up up into this half and again
I could jump in plus two and so on and I
never get any bad situations again so so
this is a back I can get a box of
permutation by sort of uh juxtaposing I
could also do it this way I could put
the I could put the M plus one to n at
the left and one to M at the right and
again uh he'll jump around and there but
it'll it it'll it'll work out fine so so
anyway you can see why that why there's
a variety of bacter permutations and now
it's time for topic three
topic three is floor plan
and this is something
that
is decomposition
of rectangle into rectangle
into sub-rect angles Okay so
um and now um
uh
I
I guess I I might as well give you an
example so um
right off
I'll take this rectangle here
and I'm going to um
subdivide it
um
I'll keep give me a minute
to write some coordinates here V3 V4 V5
and h0 not H1 H2 H3 H4
h5h6 so so this is a five by six uh grid
and I'm and I'm going to divide it into
into sub rectangles and I've
this one goes down to H3
and then I'm going to put one here
and I can carry this over on a V3
okay
um
I I want to
um I I could have prepared a slide here
but but I didn't want to go too fast to
see so G and that I had it okay so here
not so I'm going to call this uh ABC the
the rec the sub rectangles I call rooms
so I got 10 rooms here c d e f
g h i j
um
and the and the uh the line segments
that are the uh so okay so rectangle
is a room
and the and the segments
um
it's called a bound so
every room uh
has four segments that got bounded on
the top left right bottom
um and and so I've got in this case I've
got a segment h0 I've got H1 H2 h3h4
H5 and H6 and I've got I I've got
vertical segments also I cook I used a v
so I remember it's vertical this is this
is actually supposed to be one straight
line and and so uh
uh
did this uh
as as I you can imagine uh
concept very important in in layout of
vlsi uh you know making silicon chips uh
because because the rooms correspond to
uh modules or or Gates and other circuit
and the and the bounds correspond to
channel
um
so uh where uh uh electrical think uh
so so now the uh
I I should I should I should mention
that in this decomposition of rectangles
uh I I I I we always have have have the
tatami condition which means that no no
four rectangles uh have a heck have a
the same Corner Point uh
in Japan uh uh they are this what this
this wonderful uh an angel custom of of
of covering their floor with the Tommy
mats and uh and and and uh the
uh the rule is uh you don't have ever a
situation where you know something like
uh
like this would be bad okay
because because there are four
this corner you know we have four to
tell him about touching the same point
so so so so anyway uh
that that's a kind of a degenerate thing
um
and uh
now the uh
uh
the interesting thing the the important
thing is is uh when we
when we discuss uh
what does it mean for two different
floor plans to be the same because
because it doesn't equivalence there's
an equivalence between floor plans which
means that it's going to give you the
same circuit for example if you make a
chip out of it so so if uh so I so I I
can I can actually uh uh draw that exact
same same floor plan
but but it looked it looked different if
I if I put the uh if I put the bounds in
different orders so here I'm going to do
v0 V2 V1
V3 V4 V5 and and in the horizontal I'm
going to go h0 H1
H3 H5 h
h4h6 and I'm going to I'm going to draw
the exact same uh floor plan so a a went
from a from H 0 to H3 and V 0 to V1 so
it's going to be h0 to H3 and B 0 to B1
so this is going to be a now B goes uh
across
on H1
see is it is between V1 and V
1 and V3 which is just this little not
this little thing here
um so C is between H1 and H3
G goes uh
um h
1 to H2 so so G is now
the I could go in here
um
okay
and so on so so
I'm going to get d
between H3 and H5
and then e is down here
f is this big guy
h on
NJ and I claim that that this is the
same diagram because it because each
rectangle has the same boundaries
um now so so uh
you need some notation for this so I
so I I'll say for example v0
right arrow a V1 this means that V 0 is
at the left of a and V1 is at the right
of a all right
and uh H 0
is above a and and above H3
and so uh I've got 10 rooms here and and
so I'm going to you know there's
40 different relations between these
things but the but the idea that two two
floor plan are equivalent if if they
have the same relations if there's a
one-to-one correspondence that between
the rooms
like the two room a course here of
course by the room a here and and the
bounds so bound h0
corresponds to h0 H1 correspondent you
know H3 uh H2 got here and and so all of
these relations are are preserved
between these uh between these two
things
um the the I put the labels on just so
you can see what what matches between
the two but but you know I I I could I
could have made labels blank and I would
say this floor plan is equivalent to
this floor plan because there's a
one-to-one correspondence between the
the rooms and the balance
all right now
um
uh you got questions on this
yeah
please speak very loudly I forgot to
wear my hearing yeah so if you represent
the two programs
if I represent as graphs then what yeah
they share a bound it's an edge so with
the drops vs Market
the graphs are well if if you label the
yeah but you have you have to consider
that the different kind of arcs the the
horizontal Arc and the vertical Arc into
so so the graphs are are isomorphic uh
but but you have to distinguish a
horizontal
if I didn't distinguish horizontal from
vertical then then it would be a
different concept
now uh but but uh the uh
but uh you talked about representation
and of course one of the things we want
to do is represent this in a computer in
some way and we'd like to have a
representation that that equivalent
floor plans have the look the same
inside the computer or you know easy
easy to tell that this one
equals that one so um
so now I want to explain to you how we
can get a canonical form that I can that
I can that I can take any floor plan and
I can and I can draw
I can draw it in a certain way so that
both of these would would turn out to be
to have the same result
so there are 10 rooms and and for this
canonical form I'm going to use uh I'm
going to use a
this kind of paper and I'm going to give
myself
10 by 10 area to work with the one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
uh so that you can see what I'm doing I
guess I got
two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
um okay so so I'm gonna I'm gonna uh
redraw this floor plan in a canonical
way that both of these are
are going to are going to end up the
same so I might as well just use this
one to start with and uh
no you you notice that inside uh in
inside a floor plan
um
I I said we got the tatami condition so
we
there's only four kinds of Junctions
that we can have a junction could look
like this it could look like this it can
look like this or it could look like
that but we but
at the corners we only have two but
otherwise these are all all chunks are
saying and and so I I I start at the
upper left hand corner and and I put uh
I put it here and then I look at the
lower at the lower part of that room
and uh
and I and I see that uh it it ends it
ends with a upside down T Junction for a
so it's up in the lower right hand
corner it's an a which means that uh uh
uh the boundary here
the right bound is this vertical bound
V1 and uh
and then there's
there's going to be a neighbor on the
other side
um now um
and and and the fundamental idea it uh
it is called flattening
um and so I'm going to take I'm going to
take a here and I'm going to flatten it
by
moving this bound all the way to the
left from smashing a so that so as the
width has gone down to zero and then so
so this being this line is going to
extend over uh it's it's going to um
um
I'm not going to redraw the whole thing
but after I flattened a b is going to
extend all the way to the right to the
left and and C is going to extend all
the way to that but D and F and all
these other guys are
are still are still going to be the way
they were so I would just I
smash a by moving it all here now I've
got nine rooms left
and I'm and then I I'm going to find a
canonical form of these nine rooms and
later on put put a back in again
so uh in a way uh that means I want to
um
well later on I'm going to put I'm going
to put a line here and and uh
and what I'm doing is I'm I I I I I I'm
I'm flattening a and sort of setting V1
to v0 because V1 has moved all moved
over to v0
so I'm going to call this V1 here
this is v0
um now
so now I'm left with b and what kind of
a junction is is that the other at the
other side of B well B has the other has
this kind of a junction
it's it's upper right hand corner and
and so I'm going to flatten B upwards
instead of instead of left right and and
flattening B upwards is easy in this
case because I just remove it from the
diagram so I'm going to have B
flattened here
and and and
uh I'm going to change h i 1 to h0
because I'm moving H1 up flattening out
B and I'm going to put a line below it B
because uh
later on after I get the canonical form
I'm going to put B back in again on
flattening the car okay well uh see it C
also has a a junction like this after it
and and it turns out H3
let's put h
H1 here and H
a
3 is going to go here
but I'm no it's going to go here excuse
me
forget that I'm only going I'm not going
to put any H here I'm going to put H
here and C is here with uh H3 goes to
sort of H1 when I flatten C
and now
now what does this look like after I
flattened C well
um
dnf have moved up so so now they're uh
the current state is I got D sitting
here and F
and uh and G
um
and and and D is um
is another one that has has the same
business here so H5 is going to
go to H3 and so I'm going to put D here
and H5 is going to be underneath it
at this point we get a break in the
action and E
um
is you after after I slid this up then e
came up here
and E goes all the way down to the
bottom and it has and has the upside
down two Junction again and so that's
going to be a v
2 to V1
so I put an e here and I put a V and I
put a line to the right like I did with
the A and I put V2 over here
so anyway this is this is a systematic
instruction and if you if you if if I
were doing that on not on this diagram
but I was doing it on this diagram it I
would be doing exactly the same thing
because they're isomorphic according to
according to the right bound of a uh the
same Junctions are there and I just you
know
move everything up so so
um what's going to happen is uh uh it uh
I'm going to get ghij uh and that's
that's uh
uh you know and if um I might as well
write the whole thing down because this
is going on the internet
um
g h
uh
I don't pay for Arizona
and Jay has has actually a a
corner but but this is going to say V3
to V2
um so f is going to be here I'm going to
B3
and then um
the uh this is going to be an H
h v
and this is going to be both H and V
so this will say a
h 2
H5
and this is going to be H2 here
and H
I'm going to get H 4 here
and I is on the right
um I'm going to get a V for and here I'm
going to get V5 and V
and H
six okay so so this is V5 this is V6 H5
and this is each shot
four
uh
uh now so
now I've like now I've got right now I
know where the bounds are in this thing
and so now I just have to draw the uh I
I have to draw the the uh the diagram so
so I know that a goes from V 0 to V1 and
in one dimension Direction and and H 0
to H3 in the other direction so so a is
now
um
here and B is going to take over this
whole Space
and so on and so on okay well I've
I I've got it um
I've got it
here
so that's what I just constructed by
um and this is this is actually it
conical form for this uh
for that floor plan now
um
but we can do the same thing
we can oh by the way it's not a
coincidence that that it came out in
alphabetical order ABCD
but I had to choose some arbitrary names
for these rooms and so I I so that's the
way I picked them I could I could have
called it I couldn't call him anything
uh but but I chose to put them in you
know so that that this one uh you know
take any floor plan
and convert conical form look at the
diagonal and and name the rooms uh one
in or or alphabetically whichever you
want now but that same that same
procedure that we just used for
canonical form uh I I could make another
canonical form where interchange bottom
and top so instead of starting at the at
the upper left corner I could start at
the lower left corner and instead of
looking at at the junction here I could
look at the junction up opposite and and
so if if we do that same procedure again
but but we go but we go bottom to top
instead of top to bottom then we get
this pattern which is which is
it's the same um it hits that same floor
plan but it's it's canonical but it's
it's the anti-canonical form of The Ant
And so so we got two canonical form one
one has a diagonal which which goes
strictly increasing order and the other
is um uh the anti-diagonal
uh both of them are permutation
and and uh well now it's time to to say
well why uh what does this have to do
with uh Twin Trees and and Baxter
fermentation well
the second answer is the easiest to say
this is a baxter permutation
uh you know eat indeed
and uh and it it's if and only if in
other words every every floor plan uh uh
when you put it into canonical form uh
with the with the diagonal of one and
the anti-diagonal permutation of one and
that permutation is the Baxter
permutation and every backs of
permutation is gives you a floor plan so
the number of floor plans with four
rooms is 22. the
the number of accidents you know and and
and uh
uh
the connection with Twin Trees is even
it it is even nicer
um and so I uh uh let's take a look at
at the um
what what Twin Trees we we get from from
this permutation
hmm
so uh the green the green tree starts
with e
and then
um then come D so that goes here then
comes F which goes here then comes a
and comes C less than E equals here I is
bigger than e it's bigger than f
H is less than I
uh J is bigger than I G is bigger than F
less than h
uh B is um
down here
and uh do the other in the other order
we get the uh we get the twin of the
tree and that's B uh and G comes over
here Jay
h
I
C here
a
F my f is here
um
um d That's what
D is a big left Century okay d e looks
like this looks like it got this okay
now
Twin Trees and I've um
um
I did this with my computer so I I'd be
sure I get it right
um so so here are the here are the Twin
Trees that correspond to that
permutation to that that permutation
which I claim is a baxter Plantation
oh
and here we we start to see the uh
that I put dots around it looked it
looked at efij
well it turns out efij
is um
exactly the rooms that are at the bottom
of this diagram
you see e-f-i-j
and so we call that H6
these are the things just above age six
okay uh D is the is what's just above H5
what's just above age three A and C here
we go H3 is here
um uh what what about H4 that's just H
that's just H4 uh G is is H2 uh B is H1
so so
um uh these these families that we see
in in the Twin tree are exactly uh what
goes next to a bound these are the you
know H is a channel these are the
modules that touch the perception what
again
oh okay
all right I have another idea let me go
to uh
let me go to volume four but okay anyway
here we got the picture but if I go to
the answer to exercise 372
um
uh
no I I guess we can't see them both at
the same time but anyway this picture uh
is it is is in the book okay so so uh
uh yes so I zoom out and we and we and
we we can see the uh the whole guy
you know and
and uh
okay so so so now as you can imagine
that that the the the the the uh like
bgj these are the guys touching the
right thing uh those are that those are
in this tree okay
the guys uh left in V5 the guys who are
less than V4 that's that's just I
I'm sorry bgj
H H and I H and I think so this is V now
this is V5 this is V4
um and and so on uh the V3 all the v's
appear here but now on this side I got G
and C well what's that that's below H1
so so you know A and A and B are the
things below h0 so so the idea the idea
is uh to preach each of the bounds uh
you know in in your circuit you want to
know what what are the modules touching
that that channel on top and touching
the channel underneath and they occur in
the Twin tree as you know a sequence of
left links or right links
um so just a beautiful representation
inside the computer for the floor plan
now I I've got uh some
I put some programs online uh
um
because the the this amounts to a a what
you know a wonderful
Trio of of
byjections one-to-one correspondences
between floor plans uh Twin Trees and
Baxter permutation because it because uh
uh
um
you give me a backup permutation I can
tell you what the floor plan is you give
me a floor plan I can tell you what the
Twin Trees are you give me a twin tree I
can tell you what what's the unique
Vector permutation that that generates
it and those are all and all of those
algorithms are linear time they you know
the length of the permutation uh it they
all take order n steps uh to go from one
to to uh uh to the next in the sequence
and I've got a a sequence of computer
programs online uh that that implement
this and and uh I forgot to bring the
programs with copies of the programs
with me but but these are are literate
programs which means that uh you know
the intended to be read by by people
and and uh let me zoom in here uh to uh
so you can see how a sample run of the
program
um I I but by the way just
yeah thanks for focusing uh the um
I I mean I I it would if somebody's
interested they can take my programs and
uh you know convert it into an app which
will make the call of this a wonderful
graphic interface and and flattened
floor plans and you know enjoy yourself
but anyway this is this is what what my
program gives you so I type in a a
permutation and and this happens to be
the permutation of the example but the
letters are converted to numbers so this
is e d
f a c and so on J is for 10. uh and and
so this was the input and and the output
comes out and says well room number one
goes from at the left is why I I I I
guess this is top bottom left right top
bottom left right for each room and and
so it cranks out uh
the floor plan
um
for that corresponds to this Baxter
permutation and if you give it a
perpetation that's not Baxter it it uh
sneers at you and it's too bad
you lose it's not back
um now I I can feed this floor plan
to another program called floor plan to
Twin tree
and
um
and took this was the input
uh and so so it read the specs for 10
rooms and seven horizontal bounds six
vertical bounds and so here's the Twin
Trees that comes out so the first tree
is rooted at five and and it says the
five goes four at the left six to the
right so these are the left and right
links
um in in the tree
uh and uh and then I have another form
of this floor plan the twin tree which
called the TT form which which has which
produces output in another Form This is
a form uh where you first show The Roots
and then you give the uh the left and
right
for for the two different trees uh this
this was the form that's the input to my
third program which is called twin tree
to Baxter and if I if I so I feed this
to and feed this one and then I feed
that the twin tree Baxter I get back uh
of course the one I started with
so so those programs are are all online
on my home page and uh uh uh
I I have a
I I guess I I should say a couple of
things about it uh uh
before I finish but I'm almost done uh
the first thing is this Baxter to floor
plan of the ideas in there are due to
Ackerman
and Pinter in 2006
and if you look at the at the code for
this this algorithm I I I mentioned I
wrote this when I was learning it but
like this algorithm is almost too good
to be true
so I I recommend reading the algorithm
not just using them the floor plan to
Twin tree is is due to people named Yao
sorry Yao Chen
chin and Graham
and by the way this is our friend Ron
Graham
and this is 2003
and the program has several phases and
one of them is called the cool phase and
again it's a okay and and the twin tree
to Baxter is an algorithm that's based
on the guys who invented Twin Trees to
Luke and guilder 1996.
hey so so uh and and this uh uh we get
to a part of that program which is
called a stunning construction
which is in Lemma 4 of their paper so so
anyway these these algorithms I I
believe are are are fun theory that the
final thing I want to explain is uh that
explains
um
the whole
uh uh
the main connection with is uh I'm going
to draw just
four little diagrams for junction I have
a t-junction
this Junction
in this Junction
and
I can't say I suppose I have a room r
in this position
in the floor plan
then
me
elevar is here
aravar is here
in other words the right branch and
green elevar is here
and green arvar is here so so this is
the the uh the magic of the amazing
connection between all of these things
uh uh here we have the links of the Twin
Trees here we have the Junctions in the
floor plan
all right well um I'm I'm 10 minutes
over uh I was expecting to be 20 minutes
over so I'm glad I didn't but I thought
so uh
thanks for listening and I got I'm ready
for questions
[Applause]